Where motivation is low, that's
where disciplinekicks in.
Anybody who's done something
noteworthy with their lives
all have one thing in common,
and that's discipline.
I encourage you to just
write down your goals.
Starting off your day withreading
your goals and dreams aloud
gives you a boost of positive energy.
This energy can take youto places
you couldn't even imagine.
Now a cheat code to ensure that you're
staying disciplinedto whatever you're striving for
is to prime your environment for success.
Which brings me to a very important
stepof the Hi Level mindset.
Remove all negative people out
of your life immediately.
If you'retalking about your dreams and goals
and they give small, sarcastic remarks...
boot them.
Don’t letsomeone else’s
negativity cancel out your light.